bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cet autre caddie avec notre invité
ce matin arnold antonin bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes haïtien cinéastes et
producteurs vous êtes né à
port-au-prince en 1942 alors vous êtes
aussi universitaire 1 vous avez un
doctorat en économie me semble-t-il et
ce n'est pas la première fois que vous
venez en martinique
non pas alors on va y venir vous êtes
venu présenter votre nouveau film
consacré à jean jacques dessalines mais
quels sont vos liens et vos rapports
avec la martinique et ses habitants
arnold antonin bien la martinique pour
les haïtiens c'est un petit peu la même
famille et à part ça moi j'ai été
toujours très intéressé par la
littéraire pas aimé césaire aimé césaire
après d'autres plus jeunes écrivains je
suis un grand admirateur de patrick
chamoiseau de raphaël confiant et puis
ce brûleur comme un artiste plasticien
et j'ai été après la chute des duvalier
j'ai été longtemps exige de soins tiana
ici et je suis venu ici avec un anti ce
plasticien acquis et est consacré un
film six gars venu avec sig a invité par
madame landau
suzy qui avait lancé images caraïbes et
notre rêve c'était de créer une
fondation une association de tous les
artistes et surtout les signes as de la
caraïbe précisément du point de vue du
cinéma il y a un lien particulier vous
avez des collaborations
des collègues en martinique où on
partage je suis je suis venu en
martinique avant la chute des duvalier
depuis le venezuela finir un film que
j'avais quoi - c'est qu'ils s'appellent
tontons macoutes peut-il être un poète
et je voulais j'avais un guadeloupéen
mais qui vient martinique un poète henri
corbin et puis le fils d'aimé césaire
jean-paul césaire qui avait le sma le
tarmac oui le sermac le cirma service
municipal d'action culturelle de france
et ils m'ont aidé et ils m'ont trouvé un
caméraman et j'ai interviewé saisir et
je crois que les seules images d'aimé
césaire parlant de la langue créole se
trouve dans mon film a donc j'ai
rencontré il était très sympa ils
étaient contents de rencontrer anaïs
hier il a évoqué rené dp sera qui j'ai
consacré un film également qu'on a passé
récemment ici même à l'atrium et donc
voilà j'ai eu toujours des liens avec
les martiniquais et puis après j'ai été
invité à l'atrium on a passé mes films à
plusieurs reprises est actuellement j'ai
un lien spécial avec eset caraïbes et le
rotary club qui m'avait invité l'année
dernière a présenté un cycle de films et
à faire des débats avec le public
cantini caire oui ça caraïbes qui vous
accompagnent d'ailleurs pour la
présentation de votre nouveau film dont
on va parler donc est une association
d'entraidé solidaire
caractérise analytique
tremblement de terre on y reviendra
alors arnold antonin on l'a dit donc
vous présenter
depuis quelques jours en martinique
le ce film ce nouveau film consacré donc
à jean jacques dessalines pourquoi
pourquoi ce choix
jacques dessalines est un personnage
qui habite l'imaginaire je cois de tous
les haïtiens mais chacun le voit à sa
façon peut-être que c'est le propre de
ce genre de personnage mythique de toute
manière moi j'ai senti à un certain
moment le besoin de mieux comprendre des
salines alors le film est interprété
intitulé jean jacques dessalines le
vainqueur de napoléon bonaparte dont
vous considérez que c'est lui qui a au
final
a fait aboutir la guerre d'indépendance
la bataille qu'ont livré les esclaves
haïtiens pour leur liberté c'est exact
hausse à l'ouverture a combattu d'abord
pour la liberté des esclaves et
il est mort dans une prison en france
pour cela victime de la volée en
évidemment qu'il a attrapé pas traîtrise
et la liza minnelli la kidnapper pour un
civil hamine ap il a invité à une
rencontre pacifique et piles se sont
emparés de sa personne et contre tout
tous les principes de l'honneur
militaire qui existait alors ils se sont
emparés de sa personne et l'ont amené au
fort de joux il est mort donc mais jeudi
elle combattait vous la vie et tout est
contre et
le les collants des salines lui il a
lutté contre l'extermination des noirs
lorsque le bus après et l'arrestation de
tout cinq ans armée d'emmanuel leclerc
l'armée de napoléon dirigé par son beau
offrir le caire est arrivé en haïti et
ce qu'il voulait c'est m la disparition
physique de tous les noirs et tous les
métis au dessus de 12 ans et à des
documents une lettre de leclerc
notamment qui dit que la chose est en
cours on ne peut pas comme une sorte de
vengeance intraitable qua non parce que
pour eux il est évident que si c'est un
jean 102 rebelles continuer à exister
physiquement d'un pays
eh bien il n'aurait jamais pu conquérir
et ce qui était le fleuron et colonie
française colonie française et il
n'aurait jamais pu les remettre un
esclavage donc il fallait les exterminer
donc c'était une guerre d'extermination
et alors comme on n'a pas beaucoup de
temps il faut aller vite c'est donc
grâce à jean jacques dessalines à sa
bravoure à 110 ans de la stratégie
militaire à son intelligence que
finalement le le dessin le mauvais
projet de de bonaparte n'a pas été
justement accompli en haïti exact c'est
exact et des salines à une vision c'est
un homme de vision incroyable ils se
voient pas seulement comme le libérateur
d'haïti mais comme le vengeur de
l'amérique et ils le proclament ils
s'adressent aux menti ni qu'elle
s'adresse aux guadeloupéens et et ils
vont en 1804 indissociables la lutte
pour la liberté de la lutte contre le
racisme anti-noir en 1804 dans les faits
et il faut que l'âme avec panache tous
les haïtiens dépendamment de leurs
couleurs sont des noirs donc même les
métis et les blancs même les métis et
les blancs pourvu qu'on soit ici et tous
ceux qui viennent de l'étranger et qui
se réfugient en haïti 14 jours après la
proclamation d'indépendance il offre une
récompense aux capitaines des navires
américains qui ramènerait des états unis
les métis et les noirs en esclavage
alors comment se présente le film sans
trop dévoiler comment se présente ce
documentaire c'est un biopic un pur on
peut dire ça comme ça n'ont pas tout à
fait comment vous allez nous allons
s'agencer sa mise en scène c'est un
documentaire et avec des interviews des
images d archives des estampes et puis
des petites parties fictionné fille par
exemple j'ai fait un morceau choisi des
discours de dessalines et là c'est un
acteur qui interprète des salines avec
en arrière-plan son secrétaire bois
entonnèrent qui est là et des salines
appelle les français à un certain moment
les vrais cannibale
tu vois alors qu'on la fait passer dans
l'imaginaire
européenne est ici dans les antilles en
a ici aussi comme un être sauvage
barbare
tient être cruel parmi tous les héros de
l'indépendance haïtienne je pense que
c'était celui qui était le plus au
dessus de tous les préjugés et qui
malgré avoir été en esclavage dit à la
différence de beaucoup d'autres
jusqu'à l'âge de 33 ans est bien n'a pas
été un aiguille ni quelqu'un qui a une
durée sentiments mais seulement
quelqu'un qui s'était sentie investie de
d'un destin le destin de le libérer
voilà et c'est pourquoi vous avez des
bois voilà lui rendre ses lettres de
noblesse et le fer ce point de vue là le
faire connaître au mieux par les
haïtiens et par les antillais et
tout le monde pense que finalement c'est
un héros universel c'est un personnage
homérique comme les i au jour en
quelques mots pour conclure arnold
antonin justement quelle perception quel
message peut délivrer cette épopée de
dessalines au pays haïtien d'aujourd'hui
de ce début de 21ème siècle alors que l'
on le sait la situation des haïtiens et
qu'elle est elle d'ailleurs en ce moment
après tout les récentes vicissitudes
la première le premier grand message il
faut une unité des patriotes haïtiens
des gens intéressés pas haïti et pas par
les richesses et la misère d'haïti
seulement qui est un fonds de commerce y
compris pour des ong 1 sous prétexte de
haut d'actions humanitaires avaient même
on a vu au cause du tremblement terre
donc il ya ce 1er mai ça y est le
deuxième message - je crois
important de dessalines c'est qu'il faut
que les haïtiens reprenne les choses en
main qu'ils soient eux-mêmes en mesure
de gérer leur pays et de conduire le
pays vers là où ils veulent donc entre
autres choses et la lucidité aussi la
lucidité
merci arnold antonin d'avoir participé à
cette émission bonne journée émission
réalisée par claudine était le viel
merci beaucoup merci